dig
back far enough in your awareness
dig back far enough
in your awareness
empty pure
bear awareness
eternally colored
by experience
empty pure
bear awareness
eternally colored
by experience
dig back far enough
in your awareness
dig back far enough
in your awareness
empty pure
bear awareness
eternally colored
by experience
empty pure
bear awareness
eternally colored
by experience
welcome to the direct path number five
thanks for tuning in
that's a little jingle that
came through
i hope you enjoyed it
feel free to repurpose it
as you'd like
all right let's jump in
for those that haven't seen the first
four direct path videos
highly recommend checking those out the
links are in the bio below
again what is
the direct path
the direct path is the direct path to
self-realization
of the kingdom of god within you you are
god you
are source i am god i am source we
all are god we all are source we are all
infinity expressing itself and that is
what these direct path videos
aim to do
through my expression hopefully
assist with the finding process
for the viewers for them to pierce the
veil
of illusory diversity
to recognize themselves as that one
infinite creator
so that is our intention our intention
is to know thyself
two words that were written on the top
of the temple of apollo at delphi the
most
prominent delphic maxim know
thyself 2500 years ago completely lost
in modernity
and again not know thyself like
self-actualization
like the outer expression but know
thyself
in terms of self-realization the inner
path
because once you successfully
pierce the veil and recognize yourself
as the one infinite creator as god as
source as infinity expressing itself
everything that you do in your
self-actualization
will be of the absolute highest morality
and we covered that in very
deep depth in the direct path number
four video
so let's start with number one why i
make these
i recently had a conversation with one
of my
close friends andy and
it's really beautiful because
a lot of the time
we ask ourselves the fundamental
question of why do i do
what i do
and if you're in a place of
ego service to self usually what happens
is your answer has something to do with
money fame fortune
wealth vanity conspicuous consumption
materialism impressing people
that type of stuff
the true one that is self-realized
their why is because it is the it's
their expression
of infinity i do not
do this for any other reason
besides to express myself first and
foremost
i'm going to do this regardless because
this is what
is my unique expression of infinity
beyond that
if it brings value to people in their
paths of finding and their paths of
piercing the veil to recognize
themselves as the one infinite creator
awesome and also very similarly
is the case with the people in the
positions of the greatest power on the
planet
if it catalyzes
their awakening beyond egoic levels of
consciousness towards non-dual states
of being then
that's exactly what is needed in
civilization in order to ensure
long-term maximal
well-being prosperity abundance
actualization
harmony
but first and foremost it's
my expression of infinity first and
foremost and
i would highly
encourage you as well
to come from that place of the one
infinite creator expressing itself
not with an attachment of any sorts
number two there's nothing to seek
the sufi metaphysics have a very
profound way of addressing this which is
they say that
only he who is completely ignorant seeks
what is already there
and then the second part of the sentence
goes
yet it remains for you to recognize it
so this is why the game
of the ego does something
along the lines of there's nothing to do
there's nothing to seek
there's no enlightenment to attain i
don't need to feel infinity i don't need
to feel eternity i don't need to feel
bliss and peace i'm okay with my one
minute of bliss and peace every single
day
because what happens is as soon as
the being begins communing more and more
with the one
infinite creator the ego dissolves
and so that's the game of the ego
is to instruct people to stay ignorant
so that the ego can continue thriving
so that the rumination and depression
and anxiety
and anger and resentment and jealousy
and malevolence and negativity can
continue
not only affecting the being but also
permeating and butterfly affecting
into civilization
so the truest thing about you is
the impulse to seek that is literally
your lifeline to the one infinite
creator
that's your lifeline to god it is your
lifeline to source
it is your lifeline to piercing the veil
of ignorance
piercing the veil of forgetting and
re-communing
with the one infinite crater with that
diamond necklace that is already around
your neck
it remains for you to recognize it
seek your ass off
and the truth will yield but dedicate
yourself
like a 40 hour a week job
and it will yield but you have to go
that hard
and there are teachings like this direct
path
and several others that accelerate
the piercing of the veil
don't listen to the ego that says
it requires 30 years in a mountain
monastery
it does not
especially modernity needs this
more than ever
number four ah
skip number three number three
matrix d conditioning
just when you perceive the social fabric
perceive it as though it is a bunch of
subscriptions
and de-subscribe
unsubscribe unfollow the
subscriptions that are causing you to
feel
not bliss in peace on a 24
7 basis
and there's a lot of the matrix
conditioning
that has a lot to do with the perpetual
economic machinery that
is also the same thing that
creates all of the propaganda that keeps
people
asleep
recognize the pieces to that machinery
and unsubscribe from them
very similarly in your social feeds when
you look through your social feeds
unsubscribe unfollow from everything
that does not
serve your self-realization that does
not
serve your 24 7 bliss piece period
and we recognize that the matrix
conditioning
serves humanity it does it serves our
awakening it acts
like a pressure cooker
to awaken us like a drill sergeant to
awaken us
for us to know that there's something
significantly more
that we already are than what appears to
be
an obsession with
materialism conspicuous consumption
money greed ego
disharmony
unsubscribe and subscribe to what
accelerates your self-realization
number four the coat of many colors
i recently asked myself
as many of you know i've studied
all of the perennial spiritual mystic
traditions
and i was wondering
what if i had to pick would be my
favorite
story from the
abrahamic religion
so
i really like joseph in the code of many
colors as you can tell
and the
also profound similarity that that story
also has in the quran with yusuf
is also very very enriching and
enlightening
because you realize that there's
actually a lot of profound overlaps
between islam and judeo-christianity
which then you aim to
show those and harmonize the two
so the way that the code of many colors
helps
you in your process of knowing yourself
is that the more that you
become a synthesis
the more that you parse from
the absolute highest
parts of the fitness landscape across
different disciplines
the more that you parse from
the highest mountains on the edge
of civilization's knowledge graph
and you bring in all of those
most pareto efficient
data streams from the tops
in through you and you refract that
as your beautiful essence and being
the more you'll accelerate your process
and self-realization so in other words
it is
find the smartest people find the
smartest sources of wisdom and knowledge
on the planet
surround yourself with them add
all of those to your notes add them all
to your graphics
that you illustrate keep them all in a
nice lattice work
and then what will happen is along the
way you will
revisit terms you will get introduced to
new things and you'll
profoundly augment yourself more and
more towards self-realization
an example is i had held wadat al-wujud
which is of the sufi metaphysic the
unity of all being in existence
in my lattice work for a year
until i read william chitik's piece on
the ibnrabi society
where he writes that it's not just the
unity of all being in existence but it's
the unity of all
finding and i made an entire video about
this because it
threw my entire being into
a
into a shock and
it was because i had that
studied in my lattice work
which is why it was able to be so
profoundly
augmented to be viewed as all 8 billion
people undergoing their process
of finding simultaneously
and i have a nice
i have a nice graphic here that i'll
show you guys in a bit
that is going to explain
of this in a little bit more detail and
it's very
similar to that recent god's brain video
that we made on the channel so again
synthesize from
the peaks of many disciplines into your
lattice work
and that will make you more efficient
in self-realization
number five the pause and the now
we've been talking about the pause in
i believe every single one of the direct
path videos because it's
that important and it
very simply just means
use the breath which is very much the
nature of reality
use the breath
to slow yourself down
and use it as a tool
to dig back far enough in your awareness
use it as a tool
to create the space that's needed for
you to redirect your attention from what
is negative and depressive and that is
not serving you towards what is positive
and enlightening and is serving you
use your breath
use your breath
use your breath
and the more that you do that the more
you'll also realize
that that is the now
that
is the nature of our being in the nature
of our existence
the better that we get at recognizing
the power of that now
and the more that we live in that
and we use the breath to help us become
more familiar with living that
the more of a healthy
happy blissful peaceful
life we will live pragmatically and
pragmatically will also
influence all of our friends family
co-workers
community in the world the more that we
self-realize
the more we are in service to others and
the more that we
create a harmonious coexistence
what happens is you approach number six
which is the light flickering and ego
death
so
again this is a very perennial spiritual
wisdom
which is that when you get
better and better at the pause and the
now and you've deconditioned and
unsubscribed from the matrix and you've
synthesized many of the spiritual
wisdoms together
and you're pursuing that seeking impulse
with great vigor
what's gonna happen is you're gonna have
these little satoris that happen
along the way satori meaning sudden
enlightenment or you can think about it
like siddhar mishwar is the bird's way
and the idea is that as you get these
little light bulb flickers
that it happens for a second you're like
what the was that
you know what how am i feeling this
pure bear empty awareness even for just
a moment i felt it but now i'm back lost
in
thoughts and emotions and feelings and
beliefs and objects
but for a moment i felt that pure bear
empty awareness
for a moment i felt the bare
pure empty paper that all of the words
are being written on
or for a moment i felt
the completely empty pure
bear screen without any of the movies or
images or
applications or social media or videos
that were running on it
and so over time there's going to be
more and more of this flickering and
basically every single time that that
light flickers
more and more of the ego dies more and
more of the ego is dissolved
you will no longer associate yourself
with your name
you will no longer associate yourself
with your location
you'll no longer associate yourself with
your ethnicity your heritage
your lineage you'll no longer associate
yourself
with your work with your job
with your age
with what you eat
you will begin strictly abiding
that's what is meant by atom of vichara
it's the abiding
process where you abide in the one
infinite creator you abide in that
light that is becoming more and more
clearly
illuminated that is what enlightenment
means
once the journey to god ends
the journey in god begins
and it's gorgeous when the ego dies it's
gorgeous you literally
see crystal clear the one infinite
creator
being expressed everywhere including in
every single apparently
other subject human
and it's extremely profoundly beautiful
you begin acting more and more like a
mirror
of pure unity consciousness
this is where i would say that
i'm at i'm at a place where
i've approaching
number seven which is being
infinity
right now i very clearly feel myself as
an expression of infinity
but there will be times throughout the
day
where i will for a moment or two
or sometimes even maybe 10 or 15 seconds
that i will in a sense feel like i'm not
present in the now
that i've picked up some sort of um of
an onion layer or maybe
a part of thinking that is
in the past or in the present or in the
future
i should say but it's pretty fast
it's within maybe 10 or 15 seconds is
now
right back into the present infinity
expressing itself
so my you could say
light is very
clearly flickering faster and faster
towards being turned on permanently
and my ego is extremely close to being
completely dissolved
allen is completely dead
that guy is completely dead 100
dead there is a little bit of a trace of
atlas left
a little bit but i pretty much associate
myself with the one infinite creator
with
infinity expressing itself it apparently
the only trace of atlas that i even
really feel that's left
is sort of the
quote you could say goals of atlas as in
the way that atlas is
the way that the one infinite creator is
expressing itself through
atlas into
the creation and so more and more i'm
just
so disassociating from that the other
thing and this is a very common actual
theme
for many people that even
experience the light bulb fully staying
on
is that there's still some sort of a
procreative tendency
as in they're still at some point in
life when you're 30
35 whatever age that there is going to
be
a potential
harmonization that happens with an other
and then you bring another
child into the world
and so more and more that even dissolves
and it just becomes a complete
surrender to living in the perfection of
what infinity is expressing
and you just become surrendered to the
fact that infinity is expressing itself
through you and that naturally
whatever is going to happen with all of
these goals
that atlas has with becoming even a
father
is going to naturally unfold its way
and that is what is meant by the tao the
way
right surrender to the fact of living in
infinity in god in source in brahman and
just be just express
from there just surrender to that
unfolding
and the more that you become that
infinity
the more it leads you to number eight
the 24 hour bliss peace so
rather than having one or five minutes
of bliss and peace every day
which apparently a decent amount of
modernity thinks is just fine
is living in complete suffering and
depression
and misery and anger and
a monkey mind that's dragging them
around and absolutely destroying
them in their day-to-day happiness and
cortisol levels are
high in causing pathology in their
bodies
what's the solution self-realization
self-realization naturally eases you
into 24-hour bit bliss peace
that's the light bulb staying on all the
time
the amount of times per day
that i just recognize
that i am in a state of extreme bliss
and peace
in a present now that is eternal
is so high i'm starting to do that super
often and it's so amazing
because i've never been doing that
before in my life
and it's available for every single
person
and i'm still highly productive
i'm even more productive because i'm in
a state
of harmony every moment
it's extremely pragmatic
especially because then there's no
self-dealing tendencies there's no
service to self-tendencies
it's only service to other authentic
genuine loving compassionate service to
other
wise
everyone deserves the 24-hour bliss
piece number nine child humor
presence this is another
natural tendency
of becoming the
one infinite creator is that
you gain this very clear
child humor presence
where you feel free to just be like
or mo
hey and you can do whatever you want
like that
without having even
a hesitation or a worry about what
anyone else is going to think of you
because you recognize you're just
infinity expressing itself
and that you're going to naturally be
able to ebb into child humor and
then you're naturally going to be able
to ebb into something that's a little
bit more
quote serious and productive and then
those two things naturally
merge together
and number 10 just making this home make
this home
become the one infinite creator become
god become source become
infinity expressing itself
it's been eternally doing this and it
will
continue doing this so recognize that
you
are it doing that
and that's when the bliss and the peace
lands fully
and it becomes home
you deserve that we all deserve that
so undergo this process across these
direct path videos
and more and more you'll self
self-realize and recognize that
this is eternally
the nature of our existence
the paper the pure bear empty awareness
paper that's nature is bliss peace
that is eternally being colored by words
and experiences
and thoughts and emotions and feelings
and beliefs
and objects
and so i purposely made
this which i'm going to show you here on
the over the shoulder shot
it's very similar
to what
we explained in that god's brain video
and it should help also in these direct
path videos so i'll go ahead and show it
it synthesizes a lot of what we taught
in high level perception as well
all right so what you see here
is you see at the very top this you can
say is god source
infinity and it extends
infinitely as you can see
now what's happening is that
there are all of these creation designs
that are happening
there's this one over here there's this
one there's this one which is our
universe
there's this one over here and these are
all different creation designs
so these are all different universes so
you can think about this
as the multiverse and these as the
different universes that are being
created
now within our universe
there are several
creations even within ours and this
one's a r
earth and these all have different
evolutions of sentience so do these
so the whole point is for the
infinite for god source to express
itself through all these creation
designs and these this will have its own
consciousness or awareness or sentience
this will too
so will these and so this is just one
here on earth
meaning that this is literally
two eyes you know four limbs
right we have carbon based dna encoded
vehicles for consciousness for awareness
for sentience
and so you have to use your imagination
and think about
all of the other vehicles that exist to
explore expressing
as the one infinite creator so
here's our earth and then here
is all eight billion of us
i'm going to go ahead and zoom in for
you guys
it'll be helpful if i do
okay
so
what's happening here is that there's
eight
billion humans that are all finding
and you can tell that the color of their
pupil
is black that black color to their pupil
is what we have in common as god
as source as infinity expressing itself
now the different colors of their irises
are where they're at in these stages of
awakening
or the lenses that they carry
so some people still carry the egoic
most
veiled lens which here is like red like
these eyes
or maybe they've worked their way up to
a more social or ethno level of
consciousness which is more like these
these more tea lies and up to
transpersonal or worldly level of
consciousness or more blue
or these non-dual infinite levels of
consciousness like these over here or
these
so why i illustrate those stages of
awakening is because they're
the perennial they are literally
the perennial wisdom that has been
shared
across every single major person that
has studied human development
is that we have
this in many ways infinite
bliss peace awareness when we are a baby
and then we have all of the matrix
conditioning
that comes on and throws us into this
egoic
mentality that then we shed all those
onion layers
to that self-realization of non-duality
of infinity
and that we all go through that style of
development
of awakening
to shed these lenses of ego and
self-dealing
except there are some places on the
planet that don't have an
economic machinery and matrix
subscriptions like
there are places like in colombia with
the kogis where they as they're born the
mamas spend
nine years in a cave in darkness to
grow their sensitivity to existence
to awareness to non-duality to the
infinite
and then they don't undergo a process of
subscribing to matrix
that's why they become a really good
shaman throughout
their even teenage years and then the
later parts
of their life as well so that pretty
much
is the essence of what i wanted to share
in this
graphic and so what you want to do
ideally is you want to work your you
want to you want to visualize these
stages of awakening
you want to visualize them you want to
rocket yourself up
as efficiently as possible follow that
seeking impulse to that non-dual
infinite
that way you'll move away from being
these red
irises to being more like these
peach irises and then you'll recognize
that we share
the pupils which are the which is the
infinite expressing itself through all
these different creation designs
and then piercing the veil
to awaken to its own nature so i hope
that that was
insightful it's very similar to the
god's brain
video that we made so i highly recommend
checking that out i'll put that link in
the bio below
and thanks very much for tuning in i
love you tons
thank you thank you thank you and
hopefully
you've had some progress with
self-realization congratulations if so
watch the other four direct path videos
if you haven't yet
and also
subscribe if you haven't yet like the
video share it with people that you know
this would be influential for
and undergo the practice undergo the
practice set the intention of knowing
yourself of becoming the one infinite
creator
undergo the process of deconditioning
yourself from the matrix
of synthesizing from the peaks of the
fitness landscape creating more and more
of the pause living in more and more of
the now
feeling more and more of that light that
flickers the ego that dies
expressing yourself as actual infinity
and then really enjoying the bathing
in the 24-hour bliss and peace and
child humor presence and making that
home
that's all folks love utahns thanks for
tuning in
and let me know how you feel in the
comments below
about where you're at in your journey
i'll do my best to come in there
and comment as much as i can i've been
for the last couple of years been pretty
strong at getting in there and
commenting but have had to take a step
back because there's just a lot of
comments that are coming in so i'll come
in there
if you're if you're kind then i'll come
in
and i'll comment
so the kinder you are the more likely
you're gonna
get a reply so just remember that you
don't want to be
ego expressing itself and causing
other people suffering and harm you want
to be more in that service to other
mentality so undergo these
self-realization processes of the direct
path
and check out the other teachers that
i've listed in the
bio below as well that have profoundly
influenced me rupert spira bentino
massaro
love you guys very much also check out
the law of one
incredible work as well that i've been
mentioning a lot on the program
very much like a phd in metaphysics put
that link in the bio below as well
much love thanks for tuning in everyone
you will
find the diamond necklace that is
already
around your neck
dig back far enough
and you're awareness
dig back far enough
and you're awareness
empty pure bear
awareness eternally colored
by experience
empty pure bear
awareness eternally colored
by experience
dig back far enough
in your awareness
dig back far enough
in your awareness
empty pure bare
awareness eternally colored
by experience empty
pure bear awareness
eternally colored by
experience